over
under and you guessed it over you
uh you know what I like
calzones thought's wrong with this guy
what is
that I'm like an elephant okay if I walk
into a room it's like okay he's in there
how is this a child siiz soda well it's
roughly the size of a 2-year-old child
if the child were liquefied J rapio I'm
here dance up on me yes Ben is Eagle to
oh thank God you know what's sexy turkey
chili I don't know it's working
now hey how's it going it's Valentine's
Day and I'm working the late shift at
the snow globe Museum so I'm right where
I want to be we slowly pan up over a
Mossy log to see a deer drinking crystal
clear water yeah you know what she's
actually handling it pretty well
well what's up fart wads what are you
doing there
Wyatt I'm feeding your Eagle he's
starving we should just go for it you
know life there's no time he can fly
it's
showtime okay good evening everyone I'm
Leslie monster and this is Nightline wow
the sky is really beautiful it's
pollution from the Sweden's Factory it's
gorgeous but is it worth the
asthma no this town is going to hell and
a Gucci knockoff handbag girl you only
have nine toes I have the toes I have
hey Lesley have you seen Avatar I never
saw Avatar I wanted to read the book
first but then I realized there's no
book version of Avatar why are you like
this pills baby we're doing a trail
survey Leslie you're literally listening
to turkey calls is this is this not r
I love the Umami flavor stop being so
pretentious Kyle sorry may I take your
breakfast order we have hardboiled eggs
homemade tomato slices with dry seed and
leak jam and your choice of German
muffin the is a German muffin oh boy
here it
comes 9911 and we're walking okay I just
have a few more questions for you an
what if he shows up with another woman
what if one of my sleeves catches on
fire and it spreads rapidly What If
instead of tic tacs I accidentally pop a
couple of ambient and I have to keep
punching my leg to stay awake those are
all insane hypotheticals and I promise
you they won't
happen they have
happened all of these have happened to
me here what do you think of dogs love
cats love fish love
Turtles no
opinion they're
[Music]
condescending there's some secret
ingredient in these nutrium bars that
make me feel so good sugar it's a block
of
sugar can I just say and I think this is
really important so I need everyone to
shut
up I love your hair oh thank you it's
genetic and unattainable I have been
formally disciplined for breaking the
law well you know what they say you
break it you buy it this is for your
Gizmo I think you'll find it's pretty
good dear April's grandmother I said
grandfather oh oops okay you are a
beautiful and amazing woman man I hope
someday I can become half the woman you
are he's a man thank you for the $500 it
was $5 enjoy the mous Rat City he is
deaf okay do you want me to make those
changes or is it good oh phone water
putting an awful lot of suar on your
pasta this is just sugar so did the
Neighbors give you any problems anything
in possum there was a possum we captured
a psum and we brought it into your house
and it got out and it might have laid
eggs in your bed what and it went into
your laundry and your kitchen and it
touched all your bras and I'm so sorry
it's our fault we captured it and it got
out and it ran around and it was aosome
okay April Run Run April sorry an I love
you your house isn't haunted you're
lonely please get your jiggalo out of
here
ponie has been hit with the Aven flu Ty
April you're the most awesome person I
have ever known in my entire life I vow
to protect you from danger I don't care
if I have to fight an ultimate fighter
or a bear or him your mom I would take
him down I'm getting mad right now even
thinking about it I'm telling you it's
okay never stop dreaming Tom haford I
never do Chris what's your favorite food
well I take Skittles and I put it
between two Starbursts you know what I
call it Skittle sandwich that's pretty
good no I call it Andy's mouth surprise
I'm heard happily and I just realized
I'm not holding my microphone I'm going
to go powder my nose amongst other
things if you know what I
mean is she going to powder her vagina I
don't know what you mean but it had the
Cadence of a joke that's a loadbearing
T-Rex did you grow up in the woods are
you n from the movie n i much faster
than you I have bubble flex kill all
birds this is for the drill right yes
but I'm actually going to kill these
Birds for real no no just pretend right
so how I kill them like with a gun no I
can fill up a bathtub and just drown
them one at a time okay let's forget we
ever talked got it kill him Bobby ah
it's not padded joke Ben Spong quote
obviously swingers or Crashers Fred
Claus lley could one say that a book is
nothing more than a painting of Words
which are the notes on the tapestry of
the greatest film ever
sculpted one could say
that but should one any kid could do
that no kid could do that only God could
do that what is so great about the
shapes he likes the shapes okay let's do
it to it my
dudes I called shotgun everybody heard
me where's all the
faces the
president's I don't know how either of
you guys are doing this one time my
refrigerator stopped working I didn't
know what to do I just moved silence the
absence of noise one single Moment
undisturbed by the sound SS of a
children's TV program called Doc
McStuffins there is no quiet
anymore there is only Doc McStuffins
stop staring at Jerry like that well you
didn't tell me that your friend was so
beautiful a thanks Jeff not as beautiful
as my sister but you know the
law what I hope the rest of your day is
Cool Beans can you just take a look at
these photos and make sure that it's
Fairway prank yep that's
him Mr Campo piano those are photos of
three different possums why don't we
just set fire to the fats you know set
it a blaze and I'm allergic to turkey
neck really that's the best part we
should split a turkey
sometime hey sanitation sanitation in
the house tonight for legal reasons
we're not allowed to make puns about the
temperature of the meats anymore hello I
drove a riding lawn mower through a
Nordstrom there's a video that I took
it's on the internet